joining me now for a reaction james
golden known
popularly as bo snurly of the rush
limbaugh show he is a radio host at 77
wabc here in new york
and of course you can hear him
nationally with the magic of that
invention called the internet
james welcome aboard nice to see you
again sir
tammy thank you for having me on great
to be with you and wow what is six
minutes you have covered
the state of america in a way that i
think
needs tremendous attention well you know
i have to say
you know sports what's really important
about sports all of us understand this
is the nature that it shows us that you
know you can lose
a battle and win the war right that is
what a key life lesson about sports
that there's going to be ups and downs
and so i would fully hope and expect
that team usa comes back
but what do you think of my premise that
this is like a microcosm
of the attitude that is permeating
everywhere here
we see it in sports we see it with the
olympics but it affects our home life it
affects business
we saw with the poll it affects the
optimism for the future
uh where do you think this is headed and
what can we do about it
now tammy normally i would say to you
okay i'm not buying it because
athletes are so competitive and they're
worried about
their own competitive state and their
own achievement
that they wouldn't let these kind of
things hurt them
but then again look at what they are
being competitive with now the
competition
isn't about being the very best that you
can be on the athletic field
the competition seems to be about being
the best you can
for the media being the best you can
so that you can have your face on the
media proving how woke you are
do you remember when the olympics were
fun when athletes
used to used to show up we used to
marvel at their performances
marvel at their individual achievement
today
the news stories aren't about their
achievements
the news stories are about everything
but their achievements
i do see one bright spot in all this
though something i do support
and that is the number of women in the
olympics that finally are saying
hey we've had enough being objects for
you guys to look at with the little
bikinis with our butts hanging out
yeah we want to play sports and we want
to do so in a manner that we think is
dignified
and i support that wholeheartedly and i
think you know that's a great point i
know
the german team has also changed its
uniform entirely
but that speaks to the individual's
desire
to to be more powerful in the
implementation of their sport either
through the team or as an individual but
when you've got
coaches that have like popovich who's
been speaking very openly about
hating the country effectively how can
you
move forward in anything you do if
misery and resentment
cloud your mind when when competing is
can be about pride
for a company pride for the country and
if you think america's really this bad
why would you be compelled to do better
and then james the difference between
perhaps teammates
who might not feel the way you do and
the danger these days
about not agreeing on a political issue
right the resentment that comes inside
the team
and now you're wondering what your
teammates think of you if you are
pro-american imagine that and so here's
here's what we're left with and you know
this if you're a performer
if you're getting ready to do your show
or any show and someone comes up to you
before the show
with some drama any kind of drama it's
going to affect the way that you do your
show
if you can't help it these are the most
highly tuned athletes in the world
and look what has put before them before
they are on the world stage
it's a shame and you know what else is a
shame tammy it's a shame that when the
women's soccer team lost
there were many in america who said good
they deserve to lose you know this is
this
is what's difficult and yet it has
become instead of
bringing us together we see it of course
here at home with sports teams
it becomes this fight uh and you know we
can
already the ratings have indicated
americans you know we've lost
this uh and so i really thank you so
much for your perspective james great
stuff as always thank you sir
great to see you now